access to live events and conversation
with flipper nation
you watch the game take the clippers
facebook page to join
today long way to go in this one as
chauncey had pointed out
loopers essentially went two for one now
the ball back
perhaps maybe twice
defended by zubats they doubled booker
now singly covered by paul
george time to work with for booker in
the songs
you see they're trying to put zubats in
the action to try to find an advantage
somewhere
rubio walled off puts up a wild shot no
and how about avitza zubox with the
rebound but throws the
outlet away and the suns have it six to
play
[Applause]
booker this is for the win got it
wow
what a shot
by devin booker right there
unbelievable play but again that's what
the great players do yeah they find a
way
ruling on the floor is made basket
that is good for sure what a shot
devin booker today
what's the sons now three and oh
in the bubble they need help to make the
playoffs or that play-in game
they confirm they are learning a lot in
a short while here
look at the defense line paul george let
me tell you something
there's no way that paul george could
have played any better
defense than that first of all kawhi
cut him off from going to his left you
watch kawhi come over
stops them i mean that that that's just
a great offensive play i mean that was
really good defense i feel bad for
zubots
you know for getting that offensive
rebound and a little bit overzealous
trying to get the ball out but he had a
great game
ibiza did that was just one heck of a
play made by devin booker 35 for booker